in this episode of street talk unplugged
so the free energy principle um
originally emerged from systems
neuroscience as a way a principled way
of understanding what the brain does and
how it does it
subsequently the principles proved to be
so simple and so powerful that they've
been applied in a variety of contexts
now so one could almost
regard the free energy principle
as a an organizing principle for any
living system that shows
the characteristics of life
in this episode we'll be doing a bit of
epistemic foraging with professor carl
fristen
legendary neuroscientist and inventor of
the free energy principle
the basic idea is that our brains are
in the game of predicting
sensory imports to try and
infer
the causes that generate sensations and
to work out states of the world so that
we can respond adaptively
now long ago in my own personal
epistemic journey
i learned an important truth
that simple
and easy are not the same thing
our shared human journey is filled with
examples of simple ideas that were
nonetheless hard to discover
and some
that even once explained remain hard to
comprehend
their subtle simplicity belies their
far-reaching and deep consequences
examples might include the principle of
relativity
quantum mechanics the principle of
parsimony and entropy
i think the free energy principle is
another example
profound and far-reaching yet belied by
its simplicity it has on the one hand
been dismissed as a triviality or even a
tautology
and on the other
hailed as revolutionary
and everything in between
it has the potential to reshape how we
view the connection between
inanimate matter
and living things
and even to answer the question of how
and why consciousness and intelligence
might emerge
from physical matter and processes
there are of course newer attempts to
explain the free energy principle such
as carl's own recent paper called
the free energy principle made simpler
but not too simple
the paper develops by starting from a
world modeled as a stochastic
differential equation
now leaving aside the technical jargon
that means a world where all things from
particles to people to the largest
systems
all move or evolve according to two
processes
which combine
the first is a smooth flowing evolution
think of planets orbiting a star
or waves rippling over water or through
quantum fields
the second is a random process that
knocks around the smooth flow
in unpredictable ways
think of
twinkling stars or
audio static
you might think of these two processes
as a kind of order and chaos or yin
and yang
forever intertwined and enmeshed
these two
very different effects combine into a
chaotic flow
which may be
entangled in a kind of tropical storm
while still maintaining a semblance of
structure
and things
think about raindrops undulating down to
earth in a state of constant flux
yet still droplets
or a human being growing and adapting to
the surprises of life
all the while remaining an individual
physical entity
biology often asks the question what
must things do in order to exist
professor pristin has turned that
question on its head and developed
perhaps
the ultimate existential formalism
he asks if things exist
what must they do
from the foundation of stochastic
differential equations tristan
demonstrates that things which are
defined by a markov blanket must always
move towards a pullback attractor
a special set of attracting states which
maintains the integrity of the markov
blanket and therefore a thing's
coherence
and identity over time
one of the profound consequences of this
is that the dynamics of such a system
its laws of motion
will manifest
a form of flow dynamics which can be
interpreted as bayesian active inference
in other words such a thing maintains an
internal equivalent of a generative
model
encoding beliefs about the world and
itself
the thing uses the model to decide
actions and then performs a bayesian
update based on the outcomes
for me the idea that inference
something
widely perceived as
purely abstract or mathematical
the idea that it can be driven by simple
laws of motion dynamically maintaining
the boundaries between things
maintaining order
in the face of chaos
is frankly astonishing
what's more the free energy principle is
so general that it applies at all scales
of size and time
leading to an ecosystem of things
interacting across
scales perhaps in that multi-scale
active inference
we might finally find the keys to a
mathematics of emergence
and consciousness
so
it's so good to see you it's uh been
what about a year since
since our show and i've been looking
forward to chatting with you it doesn't
seem like a year yes suppose it has two
kids
yeah about it's been almost about a year
actually a little bit longer
three
time goes very quickly during the uh
career device are you all back up to
normal now or still
risking
kind of not not back up to normal still
some
restrictions and they they change very
often and
you know it's it's a bit confusing but
you know it's more normal than it was
i'll say that that's an interesting
concept right
by the way i just listened to your um uh
kurt's theory of everything podcast
right
that was that the four-hour one um there
was a very long one
i think it was at least three hours it
was the one where at the end you were
talking about de-realization and
de-personalization and getting into
psychology well almost psychotherapy if
i remember correct correctly yeah
psychotherapy that's a better way to put
it
quite often um because we do say this
about you carl that um you have a burden
of knowledge
and we mean this in the nicest possible
way so you always know five
um synonyms for a word in every single
domain of science and also i mean you
you even have a background in
psychotherapy so it does create a
tendency for conversations to
potentially go anywhere and when we
listened to kurt's interview of you last
time um i was really surprised that it
because we we prepared a lot for our
session with you carl and and um kurt
was asking some really open-ended
questions that were that were on the on
the surface quite naive questions but
they elicited the most interesting
responses from you
so um it it really made us rethink a
little bit how we
how we do everything on our podcast yeah
i suspect that part of that free ranging
um beauty was so fast
there was no hard limit of the time i
had no idea
three hours but he was he was a very
engaging young man
and i think um
part of that open-endedness was
deliberate you know he was he was just
indulging a bit of epistemic foraging
well it's funny you say that because
that that's the free energy principle in
a nutshell isn't it that we we need to
balance the entropy
back to this um this burden of knowledge
because i want to i want to ask you a
little bit about that which is um
and i find this is often the case uh you
know say for example um
a kid comes and shows you a test that
they're taking and there's a math
question on there right now when i was
their age i could have answered it quite
easily but as i learned more about
mathematics and engineering now i look
at the question and i'm sitting there
thinking yeah but there's all these
assumptions like how do you know this
variable's positive maybe it's negative
like it could be a real number you know
you have all this extra knowledge that's
entering in and impinging if you will on
the ability to answer that question and
so
i think a lot of times when you're asked
a deep question i i'm imagining because
your depth of knowledge and breadth of
knowledge is so large
you're sitting here thinking okay how
can i answer this in a way that's
precise and and accurate and so
therefore requires the use of
technical and you know accurate and
precise terms
but then for the the person hearing that
answer they may not have you know the
the requisite knowledge of those terms
and so it seems as if it's coming across
as
obscure or something like do you do you
run into that do you run into that often
yeah well i think we all do don't we i'm
you know
walking across disciplines um
you've got to get that um
you got to find the narrative that works
you know in a sense if you're if you're
taking a sort of um
a free energy principle approach to this
you're trying to establish some kind of
generalized synchrony which you know so
that my narrative becomes your narrative
but that mutual understanding does
require a commitment to the same
rhetoric the same calculus right so
you're often right a lot of theory of
mind a lot of perspective taking um
to the extent sometimes you have to
sacrifice a degree of precision
if i wanted to articulate something that
i know i could simulate a write down
mathematically
it would just take um
the kind of language which was not part
of the portfolio the person i was
talking to
to go through properly so you know you
just have to take shortcuts heuristic
surprise and the like yeah which is part
of the odds it is
einstein keep everything
as simple but as possible but not too
simple
that's the art of that well in a bit
we're going to ask you about your most
recent paper that literally has that
title
almost the uh the free energy principle
made simpler but not too simple so we're
going to ask you about that later
indeed indeed we are and it's
interesting what you say carl because
you're talking about things which are so
alien it might seem that you're pointing
out the obvious when you talk about
self-evidencing or when you talk about
the basics of probability theory but
keith and i often remark that a lot of
people just don't understand probability
theory a lot of very smart people and
it it might seem that that we're
reducing it down to the most basic um
principles but they just can't be
articulated uh very very clearly
yes now yeah and people like me sort of
lose sight of that you know there are
some basics you assume people do know
but of course it takes years before if
you're fluent
um and have all the right intuitions you
know so
that i think in part is um
an explanation for why people like me
are so often cast as being impenetrable
or very difficult to understand when
it's not but you know
it probably reflects again a lack of
theory of mind in terms of being able to
you know understand what people do know
and don't know
wonderful well i'm going to officially
introduce you carl
professor fristen is a british
neuroscientist at university college
london and an authority on brain imaging
in 2016 he was ranked the most
influential neuroscientist on semantic
scholar he pioneered and developed the
single most powerful technique for
analyzing the results of brain imaging
studies and he's currently a welcome
trust principal fellow and scientific
director of the welcome trust center for
neuroimaging
his main contribution to theoretical
neurobiology is the free energy
principle and its bayesian reinforcement
learning flavor active inference the
free energy principle is a formal
statement that the existential
imperative of any system which survives
in the changing world can be cast as an
inference problem the probability of
existing as the evidence that you exist
if you will this is what carl refers to
as self-evidencing or even autopiosis
now the system of course could exist at
any scale or time and as you might well
imagine this will lead us directly into
a discussion on complex systems theory
self-organization and emergence anyway
and professor fristen it's an absolute
honor to have you back on the show
welcome thank you very much it's great
to be back talking to you again
oh and incidentally a great summary of
the free energy principle was that from
wikipedia or something slightly more
learned
well we we like to interpolate from
multiple sources
yeah um
you know if we can just jump back
actually
to uh what we were what we were talking
about with um you know
things that are simple that are being
that may still be hard to understand
um i i if i may i want to i want to
share an anecdote with you
and and this is really this came to mind
when i was reading a recent paper the
free energy principle made
simpler but but not too simple
and the first
line of the introduction says
it is said that the free energy
principle is difficult to understand
this is ironic on three counts first the
free energy principle is so simple
that it is almost tautological
and what occurred to me there was one of
the most valuable life lessons i got in
graduate school was
i was in a cryptography and
cryptanalysis class
and it was being taught by professor
sylvio mccauley and he's since gone on
to quite some fame in the in the crypto
cryptographic space
and the first day of the course okay he
puts a secure communication problem on
the board the very first thing that he
does on that day puts a secure
communication these are kind of like
brain teasers in a way you have to come
up with a way to
solve this problem
and he goes okay does anybody know how
to do this
somebody raises their their hand and
gives them an idea and he goes no that
won't work here's why and he shows how
to crack that
a couple minutes later another student
how about this uh two random numbers
communicate no that won't work either
here's how to crack that right and so
after about uh five or six attempts from
the class maybe 15 or 20 minutes nobody
could solve it and he goes okay
this is the perfect place to begin this
course
because i'm going to show you the answer
and when i do it's going to be so simple
that you're going to say ha that's easy
no something that's easy is easy from
the beginning if somebody has to tell
you the answer it's only simple
right and i think i think you know human
human history is is just full of
examples
of ideas that are very very simple
yet took
you know the combined intelligence of
humanity thousands of years to discover
they may be very simple ideas but
they're still very difficult to kind of
grok to really internalize and and
understand i think we have those all
over science and the free energy
principle
may well be one of those so even though
it may be very simple it could be
difficult to kind of cognitively
grasp but i almost i'm almost starting
to think over the last year or so that
human cognition itself like in the
cognitive space there's there's sort of
this markov boundary between
an external world of ideas and and
internal and there's a fluctuation there
at the boundary where sometimes the most
advanced ideas they may creep into
what's in our sensory range and we can
just grasp them but then they kind of
fly out again and they're just always on
that cusp
of what we can really understand just
curious what you what you think about
that
i i think that's a very compelling
formulation of the and i've never heard
that before the the distinction between
easy and simple
as you were talking um
i was mindful that everything you said
could in in one way
be applied to evolution um uh and indeed
in terms of the yo
the
um
evolution of ideas and the scientific
prog uh
process itself
cast as
in cultured evolution you know sort of
co-evolution or evolutionary psychology
um as one special case of the
evolutionary process you could argue
that um evolution is a really solving a
really difficult problem
to disclose a really simple solution and
that simple solution of course is you
and me just finding the simplest
phenotype artifact that fits with the
eco niche that is co-constructed by
other artifacts and simple uh um
constructs
markov blankets um that constitute that
very condition i think
that's a wonderful insight um
and
the simplicity bit i think is really
quite crucial um
in the sense that
um well let's take the uh the
cryptography or crypto analysis um i'm
mindful of
one of the very first introductions of
variational free energy um by david
mckay who just applied
free energy minimization to the problem
of encoding and critical analysis from
the perspective of minimum description
lengths and compression uh which speaks
to you know
an alternative view of
um
the imperatives
for
any efficient representation or evidence
accumulation or data dissemination
scheme or communication scheme um in the
sense i mean that in the sense that you
can either read the history of this from
richard fireman and the pathetical
formulation of onto electrodynamics or
you can go right back to
algorithmic complexity comodo graph uh
complexity sort of induction through to
minimum description and compressibility
right through to universal computation
both at their heart
have this notion of simplification as
aspiring to or converging to
a minimum
complexity a minimum description and
a maximum compressibility so if you read
you and me as the products of evolution
that are the most efficient
installation of all the information that
i need to
engage with this eco niche
that we have co-constructed that exactly
the same principle emerges i guess what
you're saying is and i think you're
absolutely right that they
those kinds of principles not only
applied to our structural phenotypes and
the functional architectures
that we have in our brain and indeed uh
our bodies but also the cultured
constructs what people like uh cecilia
hayes would call cognitive gadgets you
know the things that um beyond a canoe
which has evolved but in a way very
differently from the way that you and i
have involved uh beyond that to things
like language itself you know where did
language come from how does that
simplify our sense making an efficient
representation of causal structures
structure in the world so i think
there's some really profound
common themes cross-cutting themes
in that description
and in a sense of course
spotting
which is not easy
but spotting those simple cross-cutting
themes is exactly the process that would
they are that
you're talking about
right right and i and i often get the
feeling that um
that
many of us or or many researchers out
there are all orbiting this kind of
central truth and it's not just a
there are the cultural constructs the
physical constructs and some abstract
concepts that are somehow grounded in
the core you know reality of physics and
in the universe and i feel like we're
all orbiting them and we haven't quite
gotten there yet i think the free energy
principle may be the closest you know
but there's still there's still gaps
there's still things that we don't
understand they're still missing parts
and it'll be really interesting when
when somebody finally
locks them all together and grasps that
that simple connection of them all
so how will you know when
when they've done that
uh that's a good question how would they
how would you know when you've done that
i guess for me it would be when we
really have a mathematics
uh when we really have a mathematics of
cognition
so it's it's close but but
still far away in a sense yeah
i agree entirely yeah
and that simple point
having that um i mean if you're
committed to this notion
that there is um an evolutionary process
in play um which in my world i would
read as
nature's way or natural bayesian
selection or
optimizing your explanations for the
world
with respect to the evidence the basic
model evidence format so i look at
natural selection as you know the uh the
process of uh basic model selection and
interestingly just coming back to your
example uh in your first class with with
york and well-respected professor he was
illustrating their i think the process
of basic model selection by putting
forward alternative hypotheses eliciting
them from the audience and then
evaluating the evidence for them
by in this instance falsely finally
because that particular strategy was
easy to crack
but illustrating that this is a process
of selection and
um
evincing
a deep problem which is generating the
hypotheses the models the phenotypes
from which to select so i think that
that you know that that's why i think
the evolutionary us
evolution perspective is it's so
compelling you know speaking to issues
that the difficult problems which i
think in radical constructivism would be
known as structure learning you know
it's easy to score a good structure a
good idea a good
explanation a good hypothesis a good bit
of um
code algorithm
it's easy to score how good it is but to
actually create a portfolio or an
ensemble or of alternative to build a
hypothesis space in the first place
that's the uneasy but that's a difficult
bit because what we're talking about is
just being a good scientist it's asking
the right questions by having the right
kinds of hypotheses for which
and search search search work for
evidence that again that was a very nice
example to um yeah you know to bring to
the table now completely lost what we
were talking about what what did you
bring to the table with your question
oh no no it was just it was just a
comment that um that we all should
should take care that simple concepts
are are can be very very hard and
furthermore
simple concepts can be extremely
valuable so the the
the the two lessons i learned there uh
were that simple and easy are not
synonyms and simple and trivial are not
synonyms
and you also um
highlighted the importance of
a
precise and simple way of expressing
those ideas in terms of mathematics but
i think
and what i'll i'm tempted to ask you but
i i i won't um
you know but why mathematics um and
perhaps
mathematics is the is the simplest most
self-consistent calculus language that
you you could
adopt
furthermore it is the kind of language
that you could um
use to communicate and share
in the sense of this um cultural
approach to co-evolution uh with people
who don't speak your native language
with your
uh vietnamese colleagues or you know
people who don't actually communicate
with narrative form but you can still
in a very precise unambiguous
simple way
express those ideas and those hypotheses
even mathematically and it will still be
understood at how meaningful
somebody um in another culture in
another world and you know speaking
speaking another language so i
on that view
if you um had to commit to a particular
language that it really has to be
mathematics which is actually a bit
worrying in the sense not everybody is
mathematically fluent um which brings us
back to you
you have to understand certain simple
mathematical fundamentals before you can
even start talking yeah although
interestingly
it's a little bit like tetris so
you don't you don't need to understand
that many fundaments about maths until
it has an extrapolative effect in many
different parts of experience space if
you like but um professor fristen i
wanted to talk a little bit about the
the low road and the high road
um you often say that the low road is
the mechanistic view of predictive
coding and neurons in the brain and all
the low-level stuff the high-level road
being the emergent and the
self-organizing phenomena um let's just
do the low road first we want to get to
the high road later but um we just had a
wonderful conversation with professor
joshua benzio the godfather of deep
learning and he's doing something very
similar to you um he's
got this
um this invention called g flow nets and
he's using that in place of the
variational inference technique that
you're using in active inference to
compute the free energy
g flow nets can be thought of as a
drop-in replacement for markov chain
monte carlo for computing unnormalized
energy functions but without the hand
crafted priors and um even if the modes
and the energy function are thin and far
between and in a high dimensional
setting it's a kind of machine learned
version i think you'd find it very
interesting but anyway um benjio is also
a huge fan of this distributional
reinforcement learning and balancing
entropy in a principled way and when i
pointed out the obvious similarities to
your work and active inference he spoke
very positively so you need to check
that episode out lovely i will do so
yeah i've never heard of that but that
yo
i have heard him talk before i do get a
sense he's you know he is certainly
becoming more of a physicist as he gets
older
the probabilistic physicist i should say
yeah that's that's very nice
so what's changed in the last year for
the free energy principle let me think
um
well one thing that um
interestingly we've been working on is
indeed this
communication and trying to sort of um
get towards a simpler exposition that
people
can already readily access and use in
their own in their own
um
setting
um part of this is uh until spotting
what the important simple contributions
are and what it can do what it can't do
what it's there for what it's not there
for um
so
um
trying to pair back
the found the fundamental parts of it
from those um
secondary auxiliary issues which are
more interpretational in nature so from
a technical point of view um it's just
been
staring at the ideas thinking about the
ideas and seeing what is the absolute
essence of this and trying to
articulate that mathematically as simply
as possible but um not making it too
simple
um
the
the the one
technical aspect here um
is
what is the precise role of the markov
blanket
um and
to what extent does that rest upon the
notions that you would inherit from
complex um dynamical systems theory
relative to a more probabilistic uh
construction of the kind that say and
judez pearl's uh formulation would speak
to um
probably more importantly how does one
relate to the other so how does a sparse
coupling
um
of a dynamical sword
lead to
certain forms of conditional
independence
those conditional independences then
underwrite the um the probabilistic
formulation of the coupling between
inside and outside of a of blanket which
is at the heart of the high road to and
to thickness and self-evidencing and the
free energy principle so that's
certainly been a focus um i have to say
slightly inspired by
um
skepticism in not from mathematicians or
um
machine learning or um
artificial intelligence but from
philosophy so philosophers become very
exercised about these things um
and like to drill down on the um
um
the precise implications of um
anything that they understand when they
when they read the map and certainly one
thing which has caused puzzlement in
that field
is
how do you constitute or where do you
place
a
um
a mathematical description in terms of
complex the dynamical systems theory and
in particular the theory of random
dynamical systems how do you place that
in relation to more conventional
conditional independence uh sort of
perlion um uh markov blanket so a lot of
work has been has been focused on that
and just for your interest they have the
upshot of that is possibly going to be a
move
away from casting things in terms of
uh non-equilibrium
steady states
casting things in terms of the
probability distribution of a system a
markov blanketed system at t equals
infinity as the underlying if you like
aspiration the
probability densities
that prescribe and shape behavior um a
move back to the much simpler
formulation in terms of lagrangians and
path integrals so this this actually is
a nice reflection of this
trying to get back to the to the the
kernel and the simplicity and
interestingly in this instance uh right
back to the inception of um certainly on
my reading of history uh of variation
free energy in the context of the
package formulation so just getting
right back to what is the lagrangian
what is the generative model under the
hood
how is that manifest in the equations of
motion and what does that look like in
terms of the implicit information
geometries that come from
the probabilistic concomitants of the
these random dynamical systems so
i would i imagine you you were talking
previously about um
the most recent attempt to
simplify demystified free energy
principle um uh
before that paper was actually put on uh
archives there's another one which is
even simpler much much simpler that just
excuse um all the delicate issues of
non-equilibrium or non-equilibrium
steady state intensities and just sticks
and tries to pursue the whole story from
uh front to up to end
using purely
the notion of a lagrangian and
pathological form of formulations so
technically that probably isn't terribly
interesting from your point of view or
possibly even your viewers but but
mathematically it's it it's been a real
game
getting back again that difficult
process of getting it simpler and
simpler and simpler and so that's that's
only one thing that's changed
if you're asking me what's happened um
in terms of
uptake and um
application of these ideas um
then i think yeah i think things are
moving more quickly than they were um
a year ago
and i'm talking here about
the application of or the corollary in
terms of your process theories of the
way things work or the way that you
might want to build artifacts or
algorithms um which is the active
inference so certainly there's been a
much greater uptake and interest in
active inference um that i've seen
simply by
pressuring number of
emails and and conferences and workshops
so literally um
i think two or three days ago
there was um a wonderful uh workshop at
the berlin school of mind and brain
which was just about active imprints and
free energy principle and a bit of
philosophy at the end which was you know
interesting mixture a cocktail of
intellectual challenges but you know i
was really impressed by work which i had
no idea about that was you know
ranging from um simulations of
declarative memory actually getting
little uh
synthetic subjects in a computer to
actually told you why they made a choice
so you're taking sort of a fairly
standard um
economic games or the kind of paradigms
that people in reinforcement that might
their learning might use but having an
epistemic aspect so seeking for
information to optimize their decisions
and their choices later on but then
taking um
the the active inference framework and
then putting on top of them the ability
to debare
and explain why these decisions were
made
leveraging you know what distinguishes
active inference from reinforcement
learning which is that under the hood
you have an explicit representation of
beliefs belief structures so there is a
belief based approach to any uh any
decision or any move that you might make
and you can use that to actually get
certain choices of decisions and actions
to disclose the belief state so you
essentially you can give again the
computer to tell you why why i did that
so that was a wonderful example great
stuff going on in
in robotics and your robotics um well i
say great because of myself colloquial
uh probably sort of quite narrow view of
it but i'm really impressed with you
know what these people
are doing
and what they are doing is
um
just
taking as rat off the shelf
um
the um
the particular
objective function that underwrites
active inference which is the expected
free energy
and then thinking well okay how can we
scale this up how can we make this work
and they're bringing things like
amortization and all the latest um
machinery from
learning machine learning to amortise
some of the more delicate problems of
mapping say from
high dimensional
inputs uh
to
the beliefs as quantified by the
sufficient statistics of uh of
distributions very much in the spirit of
a variational autoencoder that you know
that actually has
um at some level a very simple belief
structure or um posterior belief um and
associated with the you know with the
equipment the values of certain nodes in
certain layers but taking it into
the realm of state space models where
you know you've actually got an ongoing
dynamics and engagement as the rover has
to have
with the environment and of course the
added and
beautifully challenging um aspect of
robotics which is the inactive aspect
that it's not just a question of doing
uh making sense of the data quickly and
efficiently in a belief-based way but
using that
kind of
data simulation in order to decide
what's the best next move that will
enable you to assimilate your data
better under certain constraints which
of course you know
um are particularly present in your in
robotics so that that was very
interesting um i've noticed um there's
been a move coming back to you know to
the original um the original theme of of
communication and uh mutual
understanding between disciplines and
demand between
people trying to take these
ideas forward and converge on the
the endpoint which is which we
might might not know where we've got
that
but this simple practical things like
much of in my world much of the um
the proof of principle and the
the demos that tried to
unpack and add render transparent and
accessible the basic ideas are written
in academic uh software usually matlab
and i wasn't aware of this but no one
else uses matlab anymore
i'm free millennial but apparently you
meant to use python and julia and all
sorts of things
i'm afraid
well actually you you know
hey use whatever tool whatever tool
works um well first of all i
i'm excited to see that that you're
seeing more uptake of the free energy
principle because i think you know both
tim and i after after our show last year
have
you now now we're seeing it everywhere
like i mean we're seeing the concept
everywhere it's like everywhere we look
we think oh this is there's a connection
here between what we're talking about
now in the free energy principles so i'm
certainly a fan of people definitely
thinking about it more
trying to come up with uh practical
systems based off of based off of the
principle um i want to come back a bit
to what you first talked about which is
the mathematical developments
or exposition if you will of the free
energy principle
um and i did mention
you know the the free energy principle
made simpler but not too simpler which
is apparently
yet a less simple version than a simpler
version that you had
also published which i haven't looked at
but what i loved about
the paper that i did did look over
is the formulation of um of this as
stochastic dynamical systems that are
you know orbiting around a pullback
attractor you know so
so so they are
trying to get to this this attractor of
course they're never going to arrive
there and that was a very important
point that you made in the paper that
that hey look uh you know this idea that
uh let's say life is conducting and
optimization
is a bit technically incorrect you know
it's not doing a formal
uh optimization over the entire marginal
distribution it has a set of dynamics
that it follows so there's a dynamical
system that's kind of going let's say in
a sense downhill you know towards this
this um optimum but it's moving around
it's it's being uh perturbed by
external variation etc so you get this
kind of wandering around
around the attractor and you said that
you know philosophers get very worried
about how do you connect
um you know systems like that to to
inference or to probable inference and
you give a connection i believe at least
if i read correctly in that paper you
know that you did actually give a
mathematical connection between
let's let's show how you can take the
dynamics of the system and map it
exactly to inference so
i believe that connection is provided in
there is that correct no that's
absolutely right and indeed it is just
that connection that is the free energy
principle that you're that
and in a sense um well in the sense that
we're talking about um
it does not surprise me that you are
seeing that very simple construct emerge
in many many different fields and many
guises because that's the whole point of
just um
trying to
um
evince
something that has this cross-cutting
aspect that you should for anything that
works in the sense that it persists um
uh in the context of which you place it
then
it must possess these properties so what
what you've just said which was a very
concise and erudite
summary of the contribution of that
paper is just an expression of things
that possess persist or things that
exist so you know how would you write
that down mathematically well if they
exist over a certain period of time then
they have to have an attracting set what
kind of attracting set are we interested
in well we want the most generic um
accommodating mathematical description
of systems um
that does not um actually just qualify
this that does not go quite as far as a
quantum mechanic background-free uh
description but as close as you can get
without going without going you know
crossing the going to the other side um
and that's a random dynamical system so
what is the attracting set in a random
directional system it's a pullback
attractor so you're starting off with
well okay so we're talking about things
that exist in any given context in any
given setting
things thickness has to be defined
that's the markov blanket what does um
what does that imply having a mark of
blanket well if it exists sufficiently
long for you to be able to and uh for
the conditional dependencies to be
expressed so that you can write down
there or assert that there is a a markov
blanket then you have to have a degree
of persistence or existence
so thickness entails persistence over
time that entails and necessitates them
the pullback attractor just chill
picking up on your uh on the sort of um
you know
the the possibility of um
over interpreting the role of um of a
pullback attractor
in the sense that of course you know the
definition of a pullback attractor would
really be
the um
the attracting set that um
um
attracts all states uh as t goes to
infinity
is that a really relevant construct when
we're talking about real systems that
have the an itinerary a separation of
temple scales um and as soon as you
invoke a separation of temporal scales
which you would have to to talk about
the difference between inference and
learning learning and development
development and evolution um
are you licensed now to restrict
yourself to a random dynamical system of
the kind that could be written down by a
launchman system with an attracting set
that may
that requires equals infinity for its um
for its for its definition and clearly
not
so
you have to actually sort of confront
the
certain
interpretations of how you are using
this notion of a pullback attractor um
and that's certainly been something
that's been going on in the past year or
so now lodging conversation i repeat
with people who are mathematically
fluent but their primary agenda is more
an interpretation and philosophical
interpretation uh and what's come out of
that uh or um certainly it's one one um
um
motivation for that kind of discussion
uh is this notion of separation of
temples time scales so in a nutshell um
the uh
we've stopped saying talking about
self-organization to non-equilibrium
steady state because that implies
that we're waiting until a system has
reached t equals infinity and is at
steady state and that's never what was
um in mind
we were using the steady state and the
notion of an attractive set simply to
say that this set of differential
equations
um has a solution that is non-trivial in
the sense that it does the states don't
go off to personalize
so if they don't go off to plasmas
infinity as time proceeds then there
must be an attracting center must be a
solution a non-trivial solution and it
so happens what could interpret that
non-trivial solution in terms of a
non-equilibrium steady state solution if
you've got a markov blanket that endows
it with um the fingers and you've got
solenoidal flow uh to make it a
non-equilibrium as opposed to any
caribbean uh steady state and then the
the question comes um okay
so if you're just using the notion of a
pullback attractor instead and it's
implicit uh step state solution to the
dead city dynamics
um
does do the density dynamics of
themselves um have any um mathematical
or theological role in them and can they
possibly if they only if this the object
is only defined in the infinite future
so what you do that says well no no all
we meant was for a suitable period of
time
there are certain equations of motion
certain dynamics at play
that have a solution
and that the
the
the
way that you get to a probabilistic
understanding um of the
behaviors and the dynamics that this set
of equations or these and this dynamics
has
is just by um uh looking at their
their underlying lagrangian uh and
looking at the uh the dependencies not
um in terms of the states occupied but
in uh purely from the points of view of
the paths that the system takes for this
period of time
and then that affords the opportunity i
think this i should have mentioned this
when when last year what's what's been
happening recently uh from point of view
the people the free energy principled
then you say well what do you mean by a
certain period of time well then you get
now to
the separation temple scales so you have
this notion now
that you can understand the the paths
the trajectories the dynamics
um of this thing that is defined by
markov packet for this period of time
and then you say well let's make the
equations of motion drift at a slower
tempo scale
and then let's repeat the game and how
will we do that formally well we'd use
the renormalization group or the
apparatus of the renormalization group
and then what you have is now
you've now freed yourself from the
markovic constraint so that now the
universe has now articulated in terms of
these
series of random differential equations
where the random differential equation
at any one level supplies the control
parameters of the parameters of the
equations of motion for the dynamics at
the level below for a period of time
means that you've now have the
opportunity
to look at how
the realization of a free energy
principle say in terms of active
inference
uh at one level
is deeply literally contextualized in a
hierarchical or renormalized
renormalization sense by exactly the
same form and dynamics at the level
above so now we've come back to
evolution now we've got a slow process
in fact that's a little bit grand
now we've got
let's make it slightly simpler now we've
got a nice um mathematical distinction
between inference and learning
uh and i'm focused on that because
clearly many of your your viewers will
be watching the machine learning and
advances and in that field um and
what this brings to the table now this
uh implicit separation temporal scales
is quite a fundamental difference
between interfering and learning
and
immediately tells you that
to optimize the weights of a deep neural
network or the parameters of variational
auto encoder or germantown the serial
network
you have to do it after you've done some
data simulation after you've done some
inference
so because you've got the separation of
temporal scale both at each scale
exactly the same principles apply and
can be both formulated in terms of
the free energy principle
self-evidencing just maximizing the
marginal likelihood at that level but
the connection between the two now
enables you to think about
how learning can contextualize inference
and how inference supports learning
so um by inference here i simply mean um
optimizing beliefs or maximizing the
marginal likelihood of bayesian modern
nebulas or its elbow or its variation
free energy pounds um
with respect to belief distributions or
probability disputions over things that
change quickly states of the world so
the kinds of things that you would do
you would need to infer when doing
surveillance or doing um your speech
understanding or update in an active
um
influence sense uh speech production um
as opposed to those things that
fluctuate slowly which are the
connection strengths the weights the
parameters the laws the contingencies
that are in play in this particular
context
noting this you know there's a could be
another level above which is a slow
change church of the contest that you
can learn and then you can start to
understand
right from the helmholtz machine
right through to amortization your
notions of learning to infer this is
optimizing the slow process to make the
fast process optimal um um and uh
and as such
noting that the the way in which you
optimize the fast the slow stuff depends
very much on having uh some optimal um
optimal inference scheme or digital
simulation scheme at the past level
pursuing that argument it also tells you
well the stuff
all the way down and stuff all the way
up in terms of separation table scale so
you naturally now start to ask well
what's the scale above
the learning
and this would bring us back to this
evolution and model selection structure
learning yeah how many nodes how many
factors you know what's the actual
structure do i use a convolutional
neural network yeah all of these are
structural considerations that you could
use for example a genetic algorithm or
a launch of an assisted mcmc
at a very very slow type scale to now
optimize
the very structure of your variational
autoencoder that's doing the learning to
infer that's enabling inference in a
very fast time scale
that leads to an interesting idea so
uh you know having different time scales
for um
different levels of of the structural
learning and you know i don't know if
that's been tried out yet but i think
it's
it's definitely worth
worth trying um
i i think i i have a different question
though about about the paper and thank
you for that
exposition i was very helpful one thing
that's kind of occurring to me now
is that again
the concept of the markov blankets
are still
you know fundamental and one like
perhaps concern i don't know if i should
say concern that i had with the paper is
the way in which it it formulated
the uh markov blankets you know in terms
of the the curvature of the surprise
being zero like at least you know you
you
uh as people may remember um you know
the sensory sets are those sets which
the external world um can can uh can
control and you can view but you don't
control and your uh your active states
are the ones that you can control not
the external world and the external
world can view them and so these there
are these sort of four regions and in
the paper you define you know ways in
which let's say you can set various
terms to zero
which mark the you know the boundaries
between those those regions what i'm
kind of wondering is
do they have to be zero like what if um
what if this is generalized a bit to
have like a degree
of active stateness and a degree of
sensory stateness and there was kind of
a more smooth boundary between these
what would happen i mean would that give
us any useful
useful outcomes mathematically or would
it just get in the way and it's just
more convenient to continue you know
zeroing out certain elements of the
matrix like has any has any thought been
put into what if it was more of a matter
of degree and would that be helpful or
just get in the way now that's a very
astute question and yeah i think when a
lot of thought has been um
directed at that problem whether there
have been any useful answers and that's
that that is another another question um
so just if i can um paraphrase your
questions i think a really important one
what you are saying um is that
before we make any moves in terms of
understanding
the dynamics of things that persist in
any given context we have to define
things and
in this particular construction we are
defining thingness in terms of sparse
influences um that um
underwrite conditional independences so
the your the zero elements that you were
talking about there are absolutely
crucial um in um
defining the thing
um in a crisp and unambiguous way via
conditional independence is that just
technically for those people
who like thinking that in these terms
and zero entries in in the hessian of uh
of the system when when um where the
hessian is the um
the curvature or the um the second order
uh derivative of the of the of the of
the likelihood effectively um
and then the big question comes then
where did these zero entries come in
that defined stipulatively thing that's
in terms of conditional dependence if it
was the case that um you could you um
could not um establish conditional
independence between the inside of
something and the outside of something
then there is no way of really
separating the states that into inside
and outside
so
the
the game then um and the delicate game
and and the one which has been receiving
attention the last in the last few years
in the purely academic philosophical
literature but also the maths literature
is exactly this question
of how does sparse dynamical coupling
mainly i can't actually plus you because
you two are too far away or you don't
have
the right kinds of receptors
how does that translate into these zero
entries and then your question is well
okay do we have to be scam
commit to exactly zero can we actually
now have a little bit of um wandering
away from these hard constraints
um now mathematically i wouldn't want to
do that because as you say is much more
convenient just to sort of uh identify
um zero entries in the hessian and
implicit conditional dependencies um
under some sparse coupling so what i
would say i got two levels the answer
first of all the out the the zero the
absence of any conditional uh
or the presence of a conditional
independence
and is not a terribly restrictive or
magical um
requirement in the sense that it is just
a reflection of sparse coupling so i
think that you would put the question
really not to the dependencies and the
hessian but really to the notion of um
an influence diagram that was predicated
on a set of differential equations you
thought was appropriate to describe this
universe now if you think universes have
all to all influences so every state of
this universe
come in a dynamical sense simply the
sense of a launch of an equation or a
random dynamical system influence every
other system then you will have a suit
and you will have you will have that may
have interesting structure with it but
that structure will not pertain to
anything that can be separated from the
universe because everything's connected
to everything else so you start asking
well well can i just can i jump in here
because
i think um to a degree
much of the universe and just kind of
leaving aside
okay i'm sure there are some you know
horizons at which locality you know
locality horizons whatever but but i
think that on the scales of say human
beings we are in a soup i mean we are
influenced it's just those influences
may be
very very small you know almost
almost epsilon in a sense um and that's
what kind of worried me about it is that
look i i think i think i know that at
least in terms of physics you know there
is this this soupy influencing of
everything kind of on everything else
and so what happens if we're dealing
instead with mathematics that has these
sharp you know zero boundaries is it
going to be an act an accurate
reflection
of the more soupy albeit still
exponentially decaying
you know uh couplings
perhaps i should just ask you i mean
certainly it is the case
with um
six degrees of separation that there is
a vicarious influence that that you know
will almost certainly be non-zero but
though
did you mean those vicarious influences
because for me of course
the the whole notion of a vicarious
influence through something else
immediately invokes the notion of some
thick which means another mark of
blanket so certainly there can be
indirect influences and i'm not denying
that i'm just in terms of the physical
um it's probably a bad word he is but
just in terms of the functional form
of the differential equations
that will
evidence this precarious all-to-all
coupling by other states do you think
that um
that most universes
uh are sparse or not sparse
um so with the assumption is here that
it is the sparsity that pro that endows
this rather direct system with structure
and in fact it the exception is a
non-sparse connection um and then the
question is how do you get soupy mutual
influence amongst all the constituents
or states that that constitute that
randomical system
so you know if you didn't have that kind
of sparser you would never have a
hierarchical organization in the sense
that a hierarchy just is the lack of an
influence
that
transcends more than one level say the
subsumption uh hierarchy um
in physics and
um
well let me let me
before i forget that the other half of
your argument is much more accommodating
of the epsilon and and the fuzziness
which which brings us to some notion of
wandering sets and back to um and back
to the uh this notion of separation
temple scale so how long is it nearly
zero
um or almost zero and acknowledging that
at some point it's going to be not zero
again because things change so that
i've jumped to the second half of the
argument but
i'm interested to try and bring the
the really important uh from my
perspective notion of sparsity back into
focus and say that it is not um a
remarkable um
to um to assume lots of zeros in
influence because we do that all the
time when we write down any differential
equations just by emitting
one variable
um in a state vector from the function
that defines the equation the motion the
flow operator as soon as you omit one of
a universe of um of variables you've
introduced a zero um
a zero um um
in that [ __ ] uh in a sparsely in that
dynamical coupling
maybe you know maybe this is really the
heart of abstraction which is even if
there are
these very tiny soupy couplings we can
abstract we can just treat those all
zero eliminate them
and still that abstracted model um
reflects you know emergent behaviors of
of the things if you will of the
universe really
that we're
trying to model and i think that's kind
of this duality between between the fact
that we may have a soupy substrate and
yet still
discrete uh sparse behaviors emerge on
top of that that soupy substrate
is probably one of the greatest
mysteries for me so i don't know the
answer but i i just wanted to get your
your thoughts on it you know about
well i mean i think that's a very
important um
the question um um
i i've seen it asked um interestingly
enough um
um in corresponds with people who have
sort of um
trying to look at the origins of life
and i tried to understand
the emergence of of biotic
self-organization and from many
different perspectives you know from uh
the kind of
approach that people like kate jeffries
or jeremy england might might take right
through to um uh theoreticians think uh
to try to reproduce um
organic like self-organization by
reproducing you know the events of the
bottom of the sea you know april
uh primordial soups
in structured containers afforded by
these vents
one thing which struck me
um in these arguments
was the notion of
um
emergent behavior that had this
self-replicating aspect to it
from a dynamical systems perspective the
emergence of attractors that um have a
poincare section you get sort of um a
cycle of life emerging was the notion of
shielding
the notion of
protecting yourself
from the influence of other things um
you know um
as a way of understanding uh enzymes for
example or ways of understanding the
physical structures that lead to sort of
uh
human
sort of cell light formation formations
that notion of shielding comes back to
the possibility
that it is
the
emergence of sparsity and the
construction and the self-construction
and the autopoiesis of sparsity
the underwrites a markov blanket
building system that is necessary for
the kind of structured self-organization
that um that you're asking the question
about
so literally how do we move from a
primordial soup
to
a set of discernible things and the
answer seems to be from what i'd read
it's the emergence of certain and um
auto as uh auto catalytic uh
structures
to actually sequester and shield certain
sort of chemicals or processes from
other chemicals and in the shielding
thereby emerge the supply point of view
the mark of blankets so again we come
back to
the notion of
sculpting
structure by removing stuff in this
instance it's removing connections
creating the right kind of sparsity
where structure actually emerges from
the sun
point of interest um cole could you
define
i'm really interested in in your
definition of self-organization and
emergence and and also do you think it's
a useful
um distinction to have this notion of
strong emergence and weak emergence
could you just give us your take on
i could if i was more of a scholar but
i'm going to have to ask you to define
stronghold with emergence
well it's all about
reduce abilities i mean i think weak
emergence is a kind of emergence where
the emergent property is amenable to
computer simulation or you know similar
forms of after the fact analysis so like
you know the formation of a traffic jam
and strong emergence has this notion
that the whole is something more than
the sum of its parts i mean i i was
actually going to ask you a slightly
related question about substance dualism
right which is that you know some
philosophers have this notion of um the
mind
not being reducible to its component
parts so a materialist for example or a
physicalist would would think that do
you think there's a kind of parallel
with this notion of strong emergence and
the irreducibility of our mind and
consciousness to the
uh constituent components right
you you're clearly more versed in the in
these uh fields than i am so i'm not
going to pretend to give you i highly
doubt it can't get this instance you did
a little more than i did
however
i get a sense if if you wanted to proper
answer that question i think it would
probably come back to this um
this
separation temple scales um
and posing that question
in there to
the kinds of systems that would uh that
would constitute a renormalization group
and say is there anything that um
emerges at one level
that could be abstracted from the level
below um
and
you know
if you could find an answer um
that satisfies you in terms of the
difference between strong and weak
emergence
by looking at a system that has that
renormalization property with the
separation temporal scales then i can i
could tell you what the answer is
unfortunately i don't know because i'm
not sure what the commitments of strong
and weak emergents are but certainly it
would be impossible to understand um
one
temporal scale or one level uh without
um um writing down art simulator
understanding um the level above and the
level below so in that sense i said i
suspect that it might there might be a
strong emergence in play here the reason
i mentioned that is that of course is is
the
um is the get out and it's the mechanics
it would appeal to to resolve the um the
the sparsity or the hessian equals zero
problem so it's clearly the case that uh
even in a soup or a soup that transit
um
or a collection of well-defined cells
where where there is this shielding
and um
uh sparsity of influence that
protects or
insulates the internal dynamics of say a
cell from the external milia
at some point there's going to be cell
division at some point there could be
some uh
metamorphosis or transformation or phase
transition where it is rendered soupy
again and you would need a different set
of markov blankets a how do you go from
one cell to two cells so you've got this
notion now of wandering sense so the
markov blanket partition was nicely
described into a as a partition into
internal and external and the
intervening active and sensory states
that mediate the bi-directional
influence of the inside the outside
that partition comprises a subset so
what you're talking now is about the
possibility of wandering sets in in the
sense of burkhoff
how on earth can a set wander when it is
defined stipulatively in terms of sparse
coupling expressed as a random
differential equation or a longevity
equation well it can change if you say
well this
um set of equations of motion is only in
play for this amount of time and then
the next chunk we're going to change the
parameters of the equation of the motion
and bring it other states as soon as you
bring it other states into your flow
operators
at a slow time scale you're now
destroying the old sparsity structure
replacing it with a new sparsity
structure or possibly destroying this
sparsity structure altogether
so i think that that would be the way
that you put
putting excilon back into the game
um
but actually more than epsilon actually
allowing for the fact
that there is a certain scale of
organization in space and time
uh that is superordinate to the you know
the microscopic dynamics of your your
level of inquiry
over which you will now have a
reconfiguration of the markov blanket so
things will look as if they're
reorganizing uh so what level of
self-organization happening
not that you can't answer that question
it's at all levels because the
the context of self-organization at one
spatial temporal scale
depends
sensitively and critically
on the parameters that define the
initial conditions from the the flow
operators
that are inherited from scale above and
likewise the scale above
has to conform to exactly the same
dynamics it has to have things in it
so i think that's how you get out of the
getting to a more plastic um
semi-markovian universe a biological
universe you'd start to answer the real
questions of orthopedists i i feel a
little bit um naive in saying that the
free energy principle does autophases um
in retrospect because order points has a
lot more to it and it's exactly what
you've been talking about it you know
how do you kept these self-preserving
how does how do the fast microscopic
dynamics create the context for there to
be a self-assembled mark of blanket that
entails the fast the fast the faster
these are really deep questions
indeed
it it it's another example actually we
um we've spoken to cyberneticists like
um professor jay mark bishop and and um
he he introduced us to lots of stuff
about otto poisson um i've just got a
bit of an eye on the time so we've got a
couple more questions to get through but
that was absolutely fascinating
professor preston but um i'm not sure if
you're familiar with ilya suzuki he's
the chief scientist at openai and he
became embroiled in a heated twitter
debate a couple of weeks ago where he
asserted that large language models you
know the likes of gpt3 might be slightly
conscious and of course i'm speaking to
an authority on consciousness here when
when you spoke about consciousness
actually recently you said and i'm
quoting um the proposal on offer here is
that the mind comes into being when
self-evidencing has a temporal thickness
or counter-factual depth which grounds
inferences about the consequences of my
action in this view consciousness is
nothing more than inference about my
future namely the self-evidencing
consequences of what i do i think this
is a fascinating way to put it and keith
told me earlier that he thinks of
consciousness in a very similar way but
the one thing that is missing from this
discussion in my view and by the way
we're speaking with um good old david
chalmers
in a few weeks time but what about the
phenomenological characteristics of
consciousness uh right so we've got a
couple of minutes to do that that
that'll be fine
we could get david to watch this uh give
him my very best wishes
oh we certainly will and and by the way
if you have any questions as well for us
to ask david on your behalf i think that
would be very well you should ask if
everything you've just asked me and see
what he says
i love baby
and i also like the way he responds to
some of the more technical questions
that he gets and his response to this
one
um
i think um would probably um loop in the
notion of the meta problem or the meta
hard problem um which puts simply in the
words of andy clark would be
why is it that certain things i.e
philosophers and people like you and me
puzzle so much about our qualitative
experience and and it may sound a
strange uh question but it's very
revealing question it simply means that
if you subscribe to the notion that we
are
inference machines we are built to
actively self evidence then you are
saying that we
entail
um a generative model of our experienced
world
and if we have a dirty model of our
experienced world and we can
uh talk about and puzzle about cult of
experience we must also
have a hypothesis that first of all we
are things second we are having a court
of experience with the alternate that we
are not
um which of course then um
provides a really simple explanation as
to why philosophers uh love things like
brain and vats and the zombie arguments
yeah irrespective of whether they are
useful thoughts
the very fact that you can get some like
david chavez as a young man talking
about zombies
and people listening tells you
immediately you've come across a certain
sentient artifact on on earth that has
the uh has got a generative model that
can entertain the counterfactual
hypothesis that they don't have
quantitative experience
now you may be asking well why is that
so interesting well it's interesting
because it tells you immediately that
these kinds of general these kinds of
centered creatures are showing up um
ascension behavior
um
that
necessarily requires the ability to hold
counterfactuals in mind and i mean so
now i'm trying to work back to your
introduction of the notion of the
temporal depth and something that anil
seth might also
complement with a counter factual
richness so the argument here is very
very simple and which i'm sure you you
know but they're probably worth
rehearsing um so if you had a um a
program um that could understand
language
um
then what would be the requirements of
the underlying generative moral that it
was using to infer the um the to make
sense of the auditory stream to infer
that the meant word well for it to be
conscious it would actually have to be
able to ask questions so we'd also have
to be able to speak
um so you know that's the the first
inactive move that you know you you see
with the triple e since the the turn of
the century
so we're talking about systems that are
not just sentient in a passive sessile
wave but have sentient behavior so there
has to be behavior so your language
understanding machine has to be able to
do something it has to be able to move
or ask a question and of course then you
ask them what are the best questions
well those are the ones that comply with
the principles a bit up to a bayesian
design and then you can trace out right
back to things like or from my point of
view uh articulate that as a special uh
warm part of expected free energy but
the key thing here is that the um the
the the program of the scheme the
algorithm has to be able to move
ask a question interrogate the world uh
uh perform an experiment on the world to
do self evidencing if it's doing that
then it has to have a generation model
of the consequences of its moves
so that's the simple and big move here
that just if you want to talk about um
sentient behavior you are necessarily if
you subscribe to the fact it's all
it all entails the generative model then
you're talking about things that have
genitive models of the consequences of
um their moves their behaviors their
choices
because
those uh consequences are in the future
they um they are
necessarily um
acquire that the genetic model
necessarily acquires a temporal depth so
just saying that i have an understanding
or internal model with your psychology
could be a simulation model um and
if you're a motor controller it could be
a you know sort of a forward model um
but you're
most generally just having a genetic
model of the consequences of action
means you've got a temporary deep
genitive model and notice it's the
consequences of your actions so there's
a there's an implicit agency that
suddenly comes in into focus so now you
can use the word agent as soon as your
genitive model
contains the consequences of action
um then you can use the word agent you
can't do that can i just pick up on this
a little bit it sounds a lot like you're
saying
um it must be a closed loop process
and this rather leads back to i know you
were talking about um things like aixi
and and some of the the
information theoretical conceptions of
intelligence and and those conceptions
also rely on this notion of of an agent
acting in an environment
and
does does that seem in any way
i don't know it it feels a bit um
anthropocentric doesn't it
to use that notion of consciousness or
or even intelligence
is that a good framing yeah i i well i
hadn't quite got to consciousness at
this stage uh which which will um we
will be certainly now a and
uh
in a way that um
if you like celebrates that
anthropomorphic aspect
all i said at the moment is that if you
want to talk about um
sentient behavior um before you go to
consciousness you've got to have
temporal depth you and crucially um
you know
in having consequences there can be more
than one outcome to any act so now you
necessarily have a counterfactual aspect
to the things in your journey immoral
which brings us to my point before about
you know perhaps the best thing that um
david charmans
presents from my point of view as an
existence proof of a sentient creature
that can have counterfactuals of a
certain kind where it's not being able
to have qualitative experience
but this is an example of a
counterfactual hypothesis this is a gift
of very very sophisticated
uh systems that are probably a long way
down the path to ultimate simplicity uh
in terms of evolution uh or to a very
very slow type scale um so yeah it's a
real gift to be able to have these
counterfactuals andy clark would argue
that just qualitative experience is also
another counterfactual so there will be
a grandmother cell in your prefrontal
cortex that fires when it says oh i've
had the quality of experience of seeing
red and it has to be like that in order
for you to be able to be aware of it but
using words like awareness now indeed
self-awareness so quality of experience
first of all um underpins self-awareness
which would be the cultural experience
of selfhood um so you know there are
layers upon layers that you're talking
about here each one of them has to be
manifest in the genitive model so the
first thing is that everything i've said
so far
um in terms of agency um could be
applied to a thermostat so there's a
thermostat conscious probably not
so what kind of um system more
complicated georgian model would you
need to have in place before you could
think yes possibly that could be
conscious well the first one is a depth
of planning so thermostat just does not
look beyond
the trajectories implied by the
generalized motion and that's the
gradients that are at hand you can't see
half an hour to the future it just knows
that your things are going up or going
down in the moment very short term and
um that sort of path um formulation or
generative model but things like you and
i can go and have much greater tempo
depth and then really invert the notion
of planning and then i repeat selecting
amongst a number of different um
counterfactual outcomes evaluating them
and choosing one you get into issues of
free will at this stage but still you
can imagine writing a robot writing
equipping a robot with these kinds of
genetic models that people have done
this um would you call that said right
no then you have to have the hypothesis
that it's you doing that and you in
different different states doing that
and then you have to say well why sorry
i'm rushing because i i can see your
actions to move what's the next question
i just wanted to make it yeah
it's a very special kind of generating
model uh that even has selfhood let
alone aware that you just have has
suffered and even more rare to actually
have um somebody who who worries about
these about these things and not having
the selfhood
this is this is fascinating but you are
a computationalist then you do believe
that humans are independently conscious
so first of all um i i think what you're
saying if you are a computationalist is
that if we could recreate
all of the stuff that you're just
talking about so forward reasoning and
planning et cetera that we could
recreate consciousness in silico yes yes
i i see no reason why you couldn't
create an artifact that was
sufficiently similar to you and me um
that would um you know the qualifier is
very conscious yeah that i happen
that's fascinating but yeah because the
um the cyberneticists typically think
that it's an emergent property and its
computation is observer relative so it
couldn't possibly exist in isolation and
then that leads on to um assertions of
pan psychism where consciousness must
therefore be in everything um well
can i ask for a clarification because
yeah because i i think i'm i'm a
computationalist as well so suppose um
suppose we did create an in silico you
know chip and some software that it had
the depth of counter factual planning of
temporal planning that could in fact
evaluate its own actions and could even
evaluate at a meta level you know the
computations that are going into that
that evaluation so that's sort of full
stack almost the full recursive stack
there
would that thing be because a lot of
times what i read from
you know chalmers or other
others is a question of feeling like
what does it feel like to be conscious
right and so would that thing in your
view feel
like something you know would it have
the qualia of experience that we do yes
um but you'd have to write it into the
genitive model so you'd have to have to
write
the different feeling states as
hypotheses about how am i feeling at the
moment and then it would use or i i
would use or you would use
um all
the messages and the belief updating and
all the planning and all the um
estimates of uncertainty that attend
that planning and that's quite key
actually
the the the precision or the estimates
of uncertainty start to take much much
greater uh roles in terms of the heavy
lifting of the brief updating the higher
you get in the hierarchy so
so
i am feeling in this way um i am aware
of my cell phone
you know
i am having this quality of experience
these would all be hypotheses
um that were recognized in a good
old-fashioned variation auto incurred
away from everything that's going on
below crucially including interceptive
feelings of states of your battery your
blood sugar
and all of that good stuff um
okay so i think if i understand you
correctly and this is this is pretty
cool so
the feeling is actually a knowledge of
a certain you know
activity or trajectory like that is the
feeling is in fact a knowledge
absolutely well you could even say that
the instance of the feeling the
realization of the feeling is the
inference in the context of a a
knowledge structure that just is the
generative model that has um
representations of slots that have a
semantics of i feel like a self i feel
unhappy i feel anxious i feel in that
life you know what whatever it is that
is the best sense making the best
hypothesis or explanation
in you know
a simple but not too simple way um for
everything that's going on so feelings
uh including things like pain and this
is a you know this is quite an important
so this is not just a philosophical nice
nicety it really matters in the
treatment um of chronic pain when you're
trying to
identify the locus of pain and what is
pain
it seems that pain is a hypothesis that
certain people bring to the table as the
best explanation for all of their
exceptional interceptive things
fascinating
i want to bring in the subject of um
subjectivity because when we do try and
formalize things and i know keith is
smiling because we were just speaking
with kenneth stanley and he has a
wonderful book called why greatness
cannot be planned and the myth of the
objective he thinks that formalizing
things actually blocks us from
discovering interesting stepping stones
in life and and um
even in in the frame of our thinking it
actually stops us from discovering new
interesting knowledge and this is
interesting in in your formalism so
there is a chap called arthur eddington
uh the notorious astronomer and
physicist born in the in the 19th
century and he spoke about
subjectivity and science i think his
point was that science only tells us a
sliver of what's really happening in the
world around us and we should be a lot
less arrogant in our claims to
understand it and kenneth stanley says
that we've been too focused on
objectives and the broader story is that
he thinks society and institutions are
scared of any subjectivity or perhaps
you know
you might think of it as um system one
thinking so we always try to verbalize
and understand everything but similarly
to what you were just saying about in in
respect of of agents and and the
conscious experience and subjectivity it
doesn't feel very objective anymore when
you're talking about emotions
yes um
sorry um
just the the measure of arthritis was
was very pressing for me so that's how i
got started this game with his book uh
space driving gravitation my father made
me recently that's it
you know what's fascinating about that i
got started in philosophy because i read
his book the philosophy of physical
sciences
if only he did his family would be very
proud to be in fact that his hand
a century nearly i heard his now always
essentially lead him
absolutely but do you think there's a
bit of an interesting
contradiction there in yourself that as
scientists we struggle to formalize
everything
and
we and you can't even get funding for a
grant unless you have a clear hypothesis
and a clear understanding of what you're
doing and your papers have no value
unless you have a clear formalism of
what's going on um
that was the spirit of the argument
which i think i i certainly um uh concur
with so i
i don't see any uh real debate or
dialectic here i mean this isn't simply
a problem that we're talking about
before in terms of the good scientist um
being able to build um an apt hypothesis
space where no one else has ever gone
before and then
do your your self-evidence your
evidence-based signs but the
clearly the the problem of building that
hypothesis space you know that that that
is that that's to my mind is unresolved
your in the physical sciences um
scoring any particular hypothesis
absolutely no problem that's just
estimating the marginal likelihood of
the modern evidence or some some
variation abound on it um
and it can be you know it can be as
difficult a hypothesis space as you as
you want to consider but building it in
the first place i think that's the uh
that you know that is that is the
outstanding problem but practically and
philosophically and you know you have to
ask
are there any examples where it's been
solved well yes naturals natural
selection solved it and so it's used a
particular way of exploring in a
structured way using but say bisexual
reproduction and that sort of gives you
clues as to how you might um create and
literally do lateral thinking or
inventive thinking having ideas and
hypotheses that no one ever has had
before so um you know i
i i think that that question if i read
it properly just speaks to a really
challenging exciting and practical
challenge uh not just for sites but
people trying to build sentient
artifacts that now have in a principal
way the ability to actually have new
ideas and to test these new ideas out
and i should just add that one example
of these new ideas is that i am a person
and i'm happy or in pain you know
there's nothing i don't think they're
particularly magical about uh the kind
of
constructs we talk about um in
philosophy of selfhood unconsciousness
and self-awareness and the psychophysics
of visual perception it's just that you
know having um these new kinds
hypotheses props are not so new in terms
of selfhood because of the culturalism
that we're talking about and the fact
that
mum talks about me and it's
a very viable hypothesis that explains a
lot and actually makes my data foraging
on my epistemic uh foraging much more
efficient
just to simplify the world oh i am a
person a non-busy person there are two
cells that hypothesis perfectly fit for
purpose maybe completely rubbish i don't
know but it's a hypothesis that seems to
work really well um and when you
generalize it oh there are other persons
sort of itself self self so i seem to be
in the universe populate it myself this
is a hypothesis which is reaffirmed
through gathering the right kind of
evidence through communication affording
what caused by language and other
aspects of it cultural psych
evolutionists and psychology
that again um speak to the sort of
separation of temple skills
but
quite within this quite naturally
selfhood arises um uh
uh and one could argue uh philosophers
also will flourish and we can have
conversations about the heart
problemation that the better heart
problem as he will do
but it all rests upon at some level at
the highest level new hypotheses simpler
better hypotheses being tested by some
artifact or some markov blood kits the
thing that fascinates me though is is
that that
with the um the fep formalism you were
saying before about um self evidencing
and finding our eco niche and when we do
talk about well when we introduce
subjectivity it doesn't feel
it feels much more divergent and much
more random and that's what kenneth
stanley says he says that any any
formalism is convergent and in order to
be divergent we need to embrace
subjectivity and it feels like emotions
are the human form of subjectivity so
that kind of in my in my mind that that
makes this process feel much more random
and divergent than perhaps the formalism
would make us think
again i i don't feel there's a i can't
quite get a sense of dialect i don't
know who disagree with that um it
certainly is the case that finding your
place and you know we actually
demonstrate this in silico
using cells that differentiate finding
your place under a shared
narrative or generative model uh amongst
the population um is a free energy
minimizing solution and it necessarily
leverages or relies upon um
subject-specific realizations that are
contextualized by what the realizations
another subject has so you can certainly
um
um you can certainly
argue
that that subjectivity that
subject-specific expression of um
your sense making active sense making um
is um
a necessary part of the minimization of
the joint free energy of a number of
free energy minimizing systems even to
the extent i mean this is um
this is basically the holy grail and
taken as read in things like
computational psychiatry so yep if you
want to use
um
say the active inference um
process theory to understand and
phenotype people who might or may not
have uh schizophrenia fall symptoms or
may or may not show addictive behaviors
or have this kind of
autistic
uh expression um then what you can do is
you can use the complete class theorem
to say well look
in this game that i'm going to give you
um
there are
the complete classroom tells me that
your behavior will be base optimal
whatever you choose under some prize and
what i want to know is what are your
prize
so that means for every person every
subject there is a unique set of prize
that characterize their behavior under
ideal based assumptions that can be
read as active inference so the job now
is to try and identify what are these
this what are this person's prize then
use that to
test hypotheses that you're this kind of
person or that kind of person to try to
find some systematic structure and um
in the belief
uh the belief structures that each
subject brings to the table
yeah
before we run out of time i do want to
ask you
the the perennial free will question so
uh
you know i think and correct me if i'm
wrong but i think you you believe in a
universe that's unfolding according to
these deterministic you know still
albeit stochastic but deterministic
you know flow equations um differential
equations and so
the universe is deterministic
from that perspective and so in is that
correct would you would you agree with
that
um
sorry i did just technically um you you
have random fluctuations um
on on in a random dynamical system so
you don't get deterministic case but you
certainly get stochastic chaos uh
absolutely and just interestingly uh it
is becoming clearer that um
things like you and me um may well have
um
uh particular flows that are
almost deterministic even if the outside
is a bit random sure
yeah and i would even i would even say
it's entirely possible that those
stochastic fluctuations are themselves
highly chaotic you know deterministic
systems or even if they are
pure pure chance they're of the form of
a chance that's you know not
controllable um it's just you know it's
just sort of this truly random chance
and so in that context a lot of folks
have
a lot of trouble imagining how we can
have quote unquote
free will
from my perspective free will is
simply that a
an agent evaluates
a set of inputs and sensory sensory
things and has an algorithm that then
determines you know what actions it's
going to take you know based upon that
and if you had put in different
different sensory inputs
it might have chosen a different
different pathway like that's i'm
talking about sort of
uh
degrees of freedom if you will as free
will almost the same kind of concept i
believe that that daniel bennett um
espouses so i'm curious uh how you see
free will in the context of a a universe
unfolding
either purely deterministically or
deterministically with stochastic you
know variation i think i say almost
exactly the way that you you um you
express that um just to make the point
that um
the uh
the the fast stochastic fluctuations of
course um can also be um just um
expressed at a faster time scale using
their renormalization group so you don't
even have to say i'm committed to
stochastic as opposed to
a deterministic chaos with a correlation
dimension or greater than 10 for example
you don't even have to do that once you
allow for the separation of temporal
scales and so you can talk about it
you're a universe that is um it's no
longer markovian because of the
separation temple scales but certainly
has the opportunity at one's given scale
to have uh deterministic chaos and i
think just in saying that um you're
perfectly licensed to talk about free
will in fact it would be difficult to
imagine anything that plans and selects
one of a number of ways forward you know
those counterfactuals we talked about
before
that could not be construed as
selecting and thereby and manifesting a
piecing at least a minimal kind of
willfulness um
in the sense it has to do selection yeah
what could argue well does that mean
that natural selection is selecting you
willfully does it make a choice does it
have free will
i'm not sure about that but but
certainly if you if you
if you have a generative model that sees
itself doing its natural selection of
the best counterfactuals about what to
do or say next and then you know then
there is uh that would i think be part
of this sort of minimal selfhood um that
you know would be undeniably a
representation and an inference and a
recognization of my free will and if i
was able to infer that you were
sufficiently like me i presumably had
the same kind of jojo model i would also
further you had free will and you would
you know behave as such and i would
secure that evidence by talking to you
or just watching you and i would also
leverage it i'd also use that uh as
theory of mind to infer your intentional
stance because i see you behaving in a
way and if i behaved in that way i would
have selected that plan and therefore i
would have made that kind of choice and
that would tell me the kind of person
you are so it brings us back to the
prize that characterize all of us in
this instance
if i can infer you very accurately we
share the same prior commitments we have
very very
okay thank you amazing
professor carl fristen thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon it's been
a pleasure oh i've enjoyed myself
greatly thank you very much indeed
wonderful